i think and and i hope that this will be
interesting to you i've spoken before on
the show about what i call these
unsubscribed trolls these are people who
loudly tell me sometimes for years
i was just about to become a paid member
i was just about to do it but then you
said this and now i'm never giving you a
penny or
i have been a subscriber for years but
now i'm canceling because you said the
wrong thing or whatever i have one of
these examples for you and it's kind of
evolved over several months over the
weekend an email came in from someone
named yulia
who said i'm canceling and i'm canceling
david because you were not transphobic
enough now those are my words not their
words and i looked up their email
history this is why we keep it and
hilariously they've been emailing me for
six months and it's always about how i'm
not transphobic enough i need to be more
transphobic
and it started with i was about to give
you money
but i'm not and now it's i'm canceling
because you're not transphobic this is
fascinating so let's start with the
first email this one's from early
october where yulia said hey david i've
been watching your youtube channel for
some time i was thinking about joining
to contribute money but there is one
thing that has kept me from it you see
the most attractive thing about your
channel for me i'm a molecular biologist
is you frame your narrative around
science including the vaccine debates
but there was one thing that turned me
off there was one show
in which you talked about trans people
saying something that everyone everybody
on the left tends to say trans women are
women
now as virtually any biologist will tell
you sex is real and cannot be changed by
current scientific methods in my opinion
if you're all about science saying that
trans women are women is grossly
inaccurate
it's true to say trans women are trans
women but not women you're saying that
they are women because they identify as
women or whatever is something that
sounded hypocritical to me as a
biologist i would join and support your
channel i guess
if you stayed more accurate to science
because as a scientist i've been looking
for a leftist who would be true to
science guys is is yulia a scientist
i think it was only mentioned five times
in this email so first of all
i have never denied that biological sex
exists i have never claimed that current
scientific methods
chromosomally change
a man to a woman or a woman to a man but
i have said that for the purposes of
society and how i will deal with people
it makes no difference to me
whether a woman is biologically female
or not if that is how they are living
their life and want to be seen okay so
anyway you get the point that was in
october
november yulia writes in again and says
how are you left different from
trumpists david i appreciate your show
but this recent question about
transgenderism has caught my attention
now remember they were about to
subscribe in october and didn't they're
still watching though i think you would
be doing a disservice to yourself into
the community if you continue to blindly
follow the left propaganda about
transgenderism
i know i know inclusivity so should we
for the sake of inclusivity teach
creation science in schools your show's
most prominent feature is you position
yourself as true to the facts it is what
i and most of your audience i suppose
like about you this is not the first
time yulia speaks for my audience and
yulia goes on to say so tell me when a
male person says i feel i am a woman
therefore it is true and you believe him
and insist on everyone calling this male
person a female how is this different
from people saying trump won when he
didn't how is this not a delusion
the same way trumpists think trump won
again this is not tailored to the things
i have said on the show
but they are continuing to slam me and
then the final straw guy and listen six
seven months of being displeased with
what i say and continuing to watch
yulia has had enough why unsubscribe
david
i might not be significant for you
i'm just a biological scientist but i
have to say
i am unsubscribing and perhaps many
other people will follow again speaking
for everybody else the reason is i was
under the impression you were a
non-partisan objective reality czech
science channel
you betrayed me when you talk about
so-called trans people you evoke no
statistics you evoke no scientific
argument all you said was just in
agreement with youtube policy
i wish said it out loud i am saying this
because this is in agreement with
youtube policy but you didn't say that
guys i don't know what she's talking
about i have no idea
anyway yulia says i cannot recommend you
or your channel to anyone i know because
you lack integrity i am very sorry you
do not deserve a place in my media
stream
and i am a scientist you are not about
science i'm trying to i almost forgot
between emails two and three that yulia
is a scientist but now i remember anyway
i don't even know that i've said most of
the stuff she's referring to
the issue of trans people doesn't come
up a ton on this show
but you know what good riddance julia
good riddance i was never going to be
the transphobe that you wanted me to be
so i'm sorry to see you go but not
really and hopefully this means no more
emails that's another really funny thing
sometimes people are like i haven't been
subscribed for three years
but i'm going to email you every week
with some critique of what you said
i'm fine for you to unsubscribe but
please stop the email so that's a little
peek behind the curtain at the stuff
we're dealing with on a daily basis